so that we can get started with today's
activity science technology and energy
for Tuesday the 20th of February
2024 as is our custom we'll begin our
activity this morning by all rising and
joining representative Corman as he
Allegiance flag United States of
America
all
okay so we're here this morning to
conduct a full committee work session on
three
bills those same three bills will
be the subject of an executive session
starting at 1:00 this
afternoon those three bills are House
Bill 1600 FN relative to participation
and net energy
metering House Bill 1623 FN relative to
to State energy policy and HB
1036 relative to assessment of cost
effectiveness of the systems benefit
charge before
we move along to our work session this
morning we have a couple of
administrative duties to take care of so
I'm going to turn the floor over to
representative Bernardi to talk about
two things one is the iso New England
trip which is planned for March 15th I
believe and then um also to have a
discussion about topics that might be of
interest to to the committee for
presentations by either the doe or the
de or New Hampshire Dees or any other
entity that we might like to hear from
so representative
bernardy thank you Mr chair uh
so as you have noted uh the first item
is our is on New England trip which is
the 15th of March that is now
confirmed uh and leaving here at 8
o'clock
um I have asked that anybody who has
particular issues they would like the uh
commission to advise us on uh please
send me those I have received a few but
uh anybody else wants to do that please
uh get them to me as soon as possible
because I am going to be corresponding
with ISO New England to set up an agenda
so that we can make sure we go through
the topics that you're concerned with
and also as mentioned uh we're looking
for at least a presentation by both doe
and
de uh I sent out a note uh to folks
requesting that they send again comments
or are issues or questions they want
addressed um I've received a few I'd
like to receive more anybody interested
please forward those to me so I can get
them to the respective agencies so they
can uh plan their
presentations thank you thank you Vice
chair Thomas uh thank you Mr chair and
I'd like to add um with the chair's
concurrence and I know this question
will come up when we travel on these
trips we are representing the state of
New Hampshire and so I would um suggest
that we we dress appropriately sometimes
people do have questions on what they
should be wearing but for me I'll be
wearing my coat and tie so if you have
anything to say chair Mr
chair I agree that dorum would uh
suggest that we should all Dr dress the
same way that we would address dress for
a committee meeting or a house
session since that is the standard dress
code of the house business
casual okay before we start our work
session I have one other issue to to
discuss with the committee at our
committee meeting last Tuesday in an
exec session we unanimously passed an
amendment to House Bill
1644 and it has been brought to my
attention that there is a question
concerning the germanness of the
amendment that we adopted even though we
adopted it unanimously there was no
question of germanness at the time of
the adoption so I went to the clerk this
morning had an extensive discussion with
him he is going to take the substance of
my discussion to the speaker the two of
them are going to talk about whether or
not they believe this bill is Germaine
and they will respond back to us at some
point during the day today with a
decision about whether that bill is
Germaine or
not and as soon as I hear from the clerk
I will pass that information information
along to the rest of you representative
Bernardi I'm horrible with numbers can
you tell me what the topic of the bill
was yes
1644 was the bill to which we amend that
we amended to add nuclear to class one
uh Rex in the renewable portfolio
standard thank you and that's adding
nuclear after the date built after the
2024 okay with that out of the way we
can now begin our full committee work
session we're going to go slightly out
of order
because as we've all discovered during
this session year so far
OS sometimes delivers stuff on time and
sometimes doesn't and so we don't have
the amendment for House Bill 1036 yet
representative Harrington was at OS this
morning representative Harrington you
want to tell us what they told
you uh well I had requested the uh
amendment by 214 and I didn't receive
anything over the weekend so I went down
there this morning and they basically
said it hadn't been done yet and they
were going to work on it right away and
try to get it up to the fourth floor in
this building as soon as
possible okay so we do not have the
finished Amendment for 1036 as of this
moment so we're going to start our work
session by discussion discussing House
Bill 1600 FN relative to participation
in net energy metering and we do have an
amendment for that which was filed by
representative Corman and myself it's
amendment number
40h and I'm going to turn it over to
representative Corman to discuss what
the amendment does and to also discuss
that there may be a subsequent Amendment
coming that makes a small change
representative Corman thank excuse me
thank you Mr chair and actually I have
now a digital copy of the further
0764 and the only difference in the new
amend amendment is the effective date so
if you look at
074 it says the uh effective date is 60
days after passage the original bill was
supposed to take effect immediately upon
passage that's what the new Amendment
does excuse me
c740 I'm waiting for for hard copies of
the new new version um and sherbo sent
out copies of 0740 is that right yes I
did okay uh so I can I can walk you
through
this the original Bill if you recall had
two sections and the first section said
that a municipal host that is used to
offset the load of municipal or County
aggregations pursuant to RSA 53e that's
the net metering statute shall be a
customer of a municipal or County
aggregation and not on utility default
service with compensation for their
output made pursuant to RSA 362 2 A9
paragraph 2 and the idea of this is that
when a municipal host is um actually
serving a municipal or County
aggregation it's not going to be on
default service and therefore it's it's
reducing the load that needs to be
served by ISO so we're actually this is
load reducing that's that's the beauty
of it the amendment uh oh 740 and its
friend
0764 the same wording is there but it's
moved to a different section of the rsas
so in the original bill this wording is
in RSA
362a but it's really about Community
power and so the amendment moves it to
53a as a new paragraph uh 4 A
so that's that's the first
change any
questions I'm
sorry oh that I said 53a yeah 53 EA
so so any question you're Canadian e any
questions on that and just a reminder
this is uh actually presented to us
originally by Cliff Belo who is the
chair of the community power
Coalition yes and uh Mr Belo approves of
this change so would it be safe to say
that the essence of this change is to
move this language out of the statute
that defines Municipal host and puts it
into the statute about Community
aggregation that would be a very good
way to say it yes okay thank you is
there one other change that the
amendment makes yes there is uh so in
the original bill um there was a section
two about uh retiring uh generators from
the iso New England Market that is gone
and there's a new section to that really
is just housekeeping um it changes RSA
534 paragraph 6 where refers to RSA 53
E7 paragraph 2 that's actually the wrong
paragraph it should be paragraph three
and that's that change and this is about
uh customer data
and if you were to look at 53
E7 paragraph 2 it's nothing about
customer data uh paragraph three is
about customer
data so it's it's really just
amendment so it's a it's a pretty
straightforward amendment I think it
substantially improves the bill because
the previous version of the bill which
put this language into the definition of
Municipal
host substantially muddied the waters
for the application of that statute and
would have required um some
administrative uh changes in order to
effectively apply the new language but
by moving it to this statute it makes it
easy easier to apply it and doesn't
affect non-aggregation municip host
facilities so I think it's a vastly
superior bill and I think it warrants
support by the full committee further
discussion representative muns um I have
a a question for representative Corman
does this address the the issue that uh
folks like yourself who are in a
community aggregated power Arrangement
and have solar panels are having with
you know getting credit for that it
certainly doesn't solve the problem I
think it takes a baby step toward it by
at least getting the uh data part in the
right place but it's it it alone is not
solving the
problem representative M you have a
followup quick one so it really is
addressing just those
Municipal um Power producers yeah that's
really the thrust of the bill it's not
addressing the individual um individuals
like yourself no okay thank you
representative Harrington just a quick
comment I think anything we can do to
make uh uh aggregation and Community
power less confusing that it is because
I mean I get a lot of phone calls and
emails and people are just totally lost
is a step in the right direction so I
think this is a good
discussion well seeing none I think we
should be
fairly happy with this uh
amendment to House Bill 1600 when we get
the new version 0764 H we will pass that
out to everyone and that's the bill we
will or that's the amendment we will
take up in our exec session I I have one
other comment which is um hoping that
this will maybe go on consent or at
least uh have have no need for a floor
speech because this is the sort of thing
that uh floor speech would be no fun for
anyone I agree with
that we'll try to make that happen all
right any further
discussion okay let's move on
then I was just handed moments ago by
our extremely competent committee
researcher a amendment to House Bill
everyone so this amendment was filed by
representative
Harrington and I am a co-sponsor of this
amendment we worked with uh numerous
parties to come up with what we thought
acceptable language to solve a problem
that we believe is one
of significant importance
to Energy
Efficiency
policy so this the
original language that was passed in
House Bill 549 to essentially
rescue
the Energy Efficiency program that was
scrapped is the section of law under 374
D4 that talks about cost Effectiveness
and that's the section of law that's
being um that this proposed
amendment is looking at so what this
amendment wants to do is it want to
wants to give the Public Utilities
Commission more flexibility to determine
if cost Effectiveness tests are
appropriate to the time in which they're
being
applied and are the fairest tests that
can be uncovered and used to determine
the cost of effectivess of Energy
Efficiency
programs
now in current statute there are a
couple of tests that are used to see if
um Energy Efficiency programs are
costeffective one is called the granite
state test the other is called the total
recource cost
that those tests will still be
used when the commission tries to
determine whether Energy Efficiency
programs are costeffective or
not however the amendment goes on to say
that the commission may consider
modifications to the tests and different
or additional tests as long as they're
developed through an adjudicative
process and approved by prior by order
prior to the commencements of a trianium
emerge now it doesn't require the
commission to adopt a different test it
just says that the commission may
consider a different test well why would
it be important for the commission to be
that the grant at state test was
developed through an adjudicative
process is a pretty sturdy and Hardy
test that a lot of folks think works
very very
well and that's why the statute doesn't
require that it be abandoned or modified
way and that's important
because in a letter that the consumer
advocate wrote to this committee as his
written
testimony with regard to this the
original version of this bill he
stated and I quote if you like rate
payer Energy Efficiency you favor a low
discount rate which is one of the inputs
to the granite state
test and if you think rate payer energy
rate pair funded Energy Efficiency is
bad public policy you prefer a high
what that quote says to me is
that the granite state test is
manipulable depending on how
inputs now do we want to put into public
policy a tool that allows people to
manipulate the
outcome of something as important as a
cost benefit
test I would argue that we do not what
we want to put into
statute is a process that the commission
can use
to determine cost
Effectiveness in as objective and
neutral a manner as is
possible not via some test that could be
manipulable
manipulable based
on how
test now I know that some people
are kind
of in a mord of regulators as experts
and the only people who should
have the authority and the
responsibility for determining what's
important
in terms of Regulation but I believe
that policy makers need to set out the
do I was particularly struck recently by
a
quote
by an administrative law
judge neomi raal a judge on the US court
of appeals in the District of Columbia
circuit
who previously served as the
administrator of the office of
information and Regulatory Affairs and
as a law professor at the anonin Scalia
law school at George Mason
University she said recently and this is
a
really Salient
quote and I will quote her directly
executive branch agencies lack this type
of representation she was referring to
to the kind of representation that you
get in Congress agencies are staffed by
subject matter quote unquote experts and
bureaucrats drawn from a narrow
knowledge class siloed in their areas of
expertise agency staff often act as
policy partisans they simply do not
represent the diversity of interests
across American society and they are
institutionally not well suited to
recognize the broader economic and
policy I believe she's
right therefore it's up to us as policy
makers to produce a framework for
implementing
regulation that is as objective and
neutral as possible and that's why I
think this amendment is absolutely
necessary to give the Public Utilities
to move forward with its deliberations
in a neutral manner to test the cost
effectiveness of Energy Efficiency
programs so I'm in favor of this
amendment as you can no doubt uh
guess and uh I'll look forward hearing
comments from the rest of the committee
about the
amendment representative
McGee thank you Mr chairman um I
absolutely agree with the intention of
um of the amendment and I think that the
idea that we should be looking out for
the rate payers money and making sure
that our programs are coste effective um
is is an important goal and also to to
establish objective criteria in the
meeting of that goal again we are in
agreement what I did in preparation for
review of this
amendment is I went back and read the
order
26908 that was referred to in our
hearing on this bill by
Doe and it's about a 27 page Amendment
it's on the last triennial plan it has a
um a dissenting opinion at the end of it
and it has um it has a lot of uh
language in it about concern for various
types of financial instruments that
could be used um various ways that we
could carve up the people who are the
beneficiaries of Energy
Efficiency um there's just a lot of
there's a lot of stuff in that order um
but but what it seems to be is
um is a bit uh subjective rather than
objective in terms
of the what the order was intended to do
which was Advance the the plan that was
being put in front of the Public
Utilities
Commission um
so I looked back at HB 549 the language
there the intent there um and it was
very specific in terms of asking the
public utilities commission to not be
overturning the will of the legislature
that had been provided uh on
making uh The Joint
utilities provide these types of
programs uh through the system benefit
charge so the last place that I landed
in trying to just provide context around
whether this change is a good change was
I went back to look at
374f colon 3 and what I realized
realized was that the cost Effectiveness
section um mentions evaluation
measurement and valuation studies but if
you go to section five it says the joint
utilities shall present a joint Energy
Efficiency plan to the commission for
review and approval no less frequently
than every 3 years and then it goes on
to say up to 5% of the overall program
budget shall be expended on evaluation
measurement and verification studies
which the department or joint utilities
shall contract for as the department
deems necessary to assure program funds
are optimized to deliver rate paay
savings and to secure funds available
from wholesale energy and ancillary
Services markets so the mechanism for
the review has been left also with the
Department of energy and with the joint
utilities to provide that data to the
commission so when the plans are
presented the cost Effectiveness and the
measures that are being used are
presented as well and what I see in this
amendment is that we are opening the
door to try and muddy the waters to use
the term you used earlier um in order to
bring in perhaps uh
subjective tests that do not belong in
this procedure
because right now and I did speak with
uh one of the joint utilities about this
as well and the feedback that I got was
that from the utilities perspective they
want shity they want to understand how
the program is supposed to proceed what
hurdles they have to meet and what
information they have to
provide and when the goalposts keep
being moved by people who can come up
with other Financial tests to throw in
into the mix it doesn't really benefit
anyone it just creates instability in a
program that when we passed HB 549 we
said we wanted to be set so that it
would not cause the kind of chaos that
it did uh for the utilities and also for
the weatherization businesses in New
Hampshire um when the uncertainty is put
into into the system so I think if we
don't have an alternative to provide
that we should not open the pandors box
of
saying yeah if you can think of
something else you can use that or you
can bring it up and ask people to think
about that I I think if it ain't broke
don't fix it and I think this is a
really good example of that and
um and I I think if folks want to read
the dissenting opinion on order
2698 uh that pretty much mirrors my
opinion is that the I hope that the
Public Utilities Commission as
Regulators would try and maintain some
consistency for the policies that the
legislature has
provided and and uh that this kind of a
fly in the ointment which is how I see
it would not be entered into lightly uh
since there's been so much uh effort put
into trying to create a process that
everybody understands
so that's that's what I
excuse
me I would argue that um having read
26908 myself that the two or three two
out of the three Commissioners did
identify what they thought was something
that was broken that needed to be fixed
any further discussion representative
muns representative Harrington
sorry thank you Mr chairman um I guess
I'm a little convinced be fuddled by
some of the discussion here because it
sounds as if we have some obligation to
the utilities and the weatherization
companies to provide them a nice even
plan that they don't have to worry about
when they're getting subsidized by rate
payer money let's not forget all this
money comes from the rate payers they
pay it whether they want to or not
whether they can take advantage of it or
not maybe they're living in an apartment
and they can't they can't enjoy the joys
of Energy Efficiency or weatherization
CU it just isn't practical but they pay
for it anyways the weatherization
companies and utilities ought to be
lucky that they're getting this they
both make money off of this program and
all this simply does is say we're going
to give you shity through 2026 so for
the next couple of years three years you
can turn around and you don't have to
make any changes and if it's determined
by the Pu in the future that maybe
there's a more more effective way or
more accurate way of measuring the
Energy Efficiency programs uh to put
them up against whatever new information
may be available that the Pu can
consider this but if they're going to do
it they have to go through a full
adjudicative process and announce those
changes 12 months before they come into
effect which gives more than enough time
for the weatherization companies and the
utilities to make modifications to their
program again the rate payers are under
no obligation to make life easy as
possible for those two groups the thing
that should be counting here is what is
the most effective in Accurate Way of
measuring Energy Efficiency and that we
want to give them the flexibility if
there is a more accurate way to do that
and this would only be done full the F
full judicative process where all these
various players and actors could come in
and have their day in front of the Pu
and state why they should change or why
they shouldn't but I just think giving
them flexibility is just common
sense representative Ms thank you Mr
chair um I I am befuddled as well
um on on the one hand I I'm hearing that
um we should leave it to the legislature
to set
policy and um I believe this legislature
did that when they passed HB 549 and
expressed the um the will of the
legislature that the particular tests
that are currently in statute should be
used um um yet I'm hearing um that we
want to pass this amendment to give the
executive branch
flexibility um which you know goes
counter to the argument that the
legislature should be the one setting
policy so it it seems like we want to
have both sides and I'm uh I'm
confused I'd like to clear up your
confusion all this legislation says is
that the people who are responsible for
determining whether cost Effectiveness
the coste effectiveness St um standard
is met need to have the flexibility to
consider all the possible tests that
could be used to find one that's the
most accurate now it may be the ones
that have already been identified but
should we prude them from looking at
others that's all the amendment says
representative
Ms yet in the quote that you read you
you you highlighted the fact that we
should not um
trust subject matter experts in the
executive branch to make those
decisions no that's not what the quote
said the quote said
that those subject matter experts are no
different from the rest of us and they
can occasionally Ally be partisan but if
you set up policy in such a way to be as
objective as possible you can amarate
the partisan differences that we all
have we live in a pluralistic society we
have to accommodate the differing views
of everyone to the degree that we can
and the way we do that is by setting up
good
sound
policy that eliminates as much as
possible the objectiveness of
partisanship subjectiveness of a
partisanship representative
Ms but but isn't that what happened when
HB 549 was passed the Executive Branch
the Pu took an action that the
legislature disagreed with so the
legislature exercising its legislative
power and Duty decided that that was not
the direction that the legislature
wanted the executive branch to go and
therefore the they passed HB 549 which
specified what the test should be
overriding the
Pu I don't think they overrode the Pu
with regard to the tests the tests were
already being
used what HB 549 did was restore the
entire program and what this bill does
is it modifies the existing restored
program to make it more flexible and to
make it potentially less partisan and
more
objective representative rolds had a
comment thank you Mr chairman um I guess
I'm I'm not going to comment directly on
um on the bill um except that I'm I'm
wanting to respond to my colleague
representative Harrington's uh
characterization of um the systems
benefit benefits charge and the Energy
Efficiency programs as
subsidies and some sort of giveaways to
you
know weatherization companies um that's
not what the systems benefits charge is
that's not what Energy Efficiency
programs are
about
uh the systems benefits charge and
Energy Efficiency programs like New
Hampshire saves are similar to to
programs that over half well over half
of the states in this country have there
a recognition that Energy Efficiency as
a resource is uh different from a supply
side
resource uh no one can build an a large
Energy Efficiency
plant uh Energy Efficiency must be
procured in very small amounts from
Individual homes and businesses and
government-owned buildings uh every
place where energy is used and systems
benefits charges and the programs that
they support
represent uh limited but
strategic uh Collective investment in
the resource of Energy
Efficiency and uh you know there's 30
plus years of um you know scholar ship
and Analysis uh again across the country
in which New Hampshire and our state's
utilities have
participated um everyone wants to make
sure that the Strategic Investments made
with the assistance benefit charge are
coste effective uh and you know that's
where things like the granite state test
come from and um you know I agree with
the colleague the comments of my
colleague representative m when he
points out that the back and forth that
came from the pu's order you know
gutting New Hampshire saves a few years
ago resulted in the in the the
legislature's response in HB
549 um and you know I don't see the need
for the legislature to continue to
Tinker with
um with the pu's
operation uh of of these programs uh the
granite state test we've all said in
here arrived at
through much public input uh much
scholarship and Analysis behind it and
um it works and we should leave it
alone further discussion representative
Vice chair Thomas thank you Mr chair um
I have listened to both sides here and
to be honest I think there were good
arguments made on both sides what I what
I hear and interpret is that if you if
you believe that the legislature is
infallible and that you have a Ironclad
system that you never ever want changed
because it's perfect and you don't want
any outside influence in it then you
would probably not support this
amendment however if you feel that um
the legislature and at times that may be
correct sometimes the legislature does
want to say to people this is the way we
want it we want no change and we want no
no deviation because that's what we want
but sometimes we may feel that there's
something out there where okay it's good
now but maybe there's something better
out there maybe we have people that come
on board later on that either find a new
way or maybe parameters change and maybe
the legislature may want to give a
little bit of flexibility for a chance
to make changes faster than it would be
under a legislative process for
something something that affects rate
payers I think if you believe that in
this case legislature um is thinking
ahead that there might be something new
in the future that uh uh uh that there
might be some Innovative uh processes
out there that would be styed if we
didn't pass the amendment and maybe then
you would support this amendment to give
that that type of uh of leeway I believe
in this case I would support this
amendment because of I would like to
give the I would like to leave the door
open for potential innovation in in the
future to allow people to adjust on the
fly to certain issues and I think this
is one case where I think it could help
out rate payers so that's why I would
support this
amendment thank you further
discussion representative McGee thank
you Mr chair um i' I'd like to do a
couple of things um first of all I
think based on reading the order it it
appears that the question comes up for
needing a fix from concerns around
whether the valuation of the you know
the cost benefit analysis is is adequate
and um it's a it's a one now and the
question had been brought up in pu
hearings well what about if it was a two
you know so that kind of thing it's like
yes well that would be that would be
double the cost benefit in terms of the
the raw number MERS but when I talked
with triennial planners for the
utilities about their perception of how
these discussions are going at the
Public Utilities Commission their
perception is not that those kinds of
posings are helpful and what they
basically said to me is uh if you say
well 70% of the benefit is going to 20%
of the rate payers that is exactly what
Energy Efficiency programs are designed
to do is is they're designed to provide
money to the people who are eligible and
capable of doing energy projects when
they can do them in order to provide the
state of New Hampshire with a demand
side lever that allows us to stop
digging the hole of needing more and
more uh outside energy being brought
into the state right so if we want
energy Independence and we throw around
Concepts that we all sort of agree on
how do we get there Energy Efficiency is
abs absolutely the best tool and we have
heard you know we've heard testimony
after testimony from people who really
know that this is how you make a dent
and so what we did is we said here's a
program here are the parameters around
the program this is what we want you to
do we want you to invest like this we
want you to approve or deny a plan based
on changes to the plan and we want the
joint utilities and the department of
energy to work together to make sure the
thing that I read to you earlier right
that there is evaluation measurement and
verification studies provided to show
that we are delivering rate payer
savings that is already in the law that
is in section five which is subsequent
plan and update filings when you put
this in section 4 just because it
relates to cost Effectiveness it
contradicts the rest of the law it also
confuses the people who are actually
doing the work so it isn't an advantage
by saying you can now
bring you can bring variables into the
system that have not been vetted just to
say hey if you feel like you want
something you'll be able to throw things
up in the air that is that is not what
we've been working towards as a
legislature and so um I again would I
see chairman you've got the piece I
handed down to you I just made a couple
of copies of that section because I was
surprised when I started reading more to
realize that we already have a cost
Effectiveness test we already have a way
of reviewing and in any one of these
proceedings these things can be broached
if there's a decision that inputs need
to change those discussions can happen
in these in these adjudicative
proceedings there's nothing prohibiting
that I think this opens a dangerous door
because it is non-conclusive it is
non-conclusive it is saying you know if
you want to throw a wrench in this you
can do that even though we have no idea
uh what your objective is and I think
that that is taking Us in the opposite
direction of what we did with 549 and I
would I would I would caution against
doing
it okay thank you representative McGee
I'm going to suggest that we need to
move on pretty quickly here because we
have another bill that we want us
discuss and we have to uh cut this short
about
11:20 in order to have uh caucuses for
both our caucuses so representative
Bernardi I'll give you the last
word thank you Mr chair uh as I look at
this amendment it's it's it's very
simple it basically says that we're
going to continue to use the the current
tests that uh that are used to assess
coste Effectiveness and if in
adjudicative process is uh it moves
forward you can look at other methods as
well it doesn't change the ultimate goal
of of addressing whether we're going to
um
use the system benefits charge to you
know Advance those goals at all it it it
just says we're going to have the
opportunity if in an adjudicative
process something better or more useful
can be teased out we're going to add
that to the overall mix I don't see that
as a problem I see that as a
benefit thank you okay I'm passing out
now an amendment to house bill
dfn it is amendment number
34h which I'm offering or I will be
offering on this
legislation
and I'm going to wait a minute for the
copies to
circulate and then I'm going to go
through the changes in the build excuse
me
open close this one open the next well
this is just a work session so we we
move from one to the other seamlessly we
them okay so let's go through the
changes that are made and there are
quite a few of them I I will admit
changes that were made into in Amendment
0734 so the first
change is that the word dispatchable has
been
removed it seems that dispatchable was a
word that offended people although I
don't know why but um I took it out
because affordable reliable and secure
energy res
resources adequately covers I think um
what we need to protect here in the
Hampshire so that's a a change that gets
um based on the original filed or as as
introduced Bill lines two five 8
14 22 etc etc
etc so that word is now removed from the
statute
altogether
next big change
is
um on
page
two of the original Bill lines 16 and 17
that text has been entirely stricken
from the amendment that text no longer
uh
appears begin the text begin oh I'm
sorry the text uh begin with the
the um sub paragraph heading of a
lowercase G and it says New Hampshire
shall promote the use of clean energy
sources Etc so that text no longer
appears there another major change is
nine in the
amendment that would be page two lines 4
read excuse me New Hampshire shall
pursue energy conservation and
efficiency according to Market
principles and without state government
subsidies it now reads New Hampshire
shall pursue energy conservation and
efficiency according to Market
principles and Accord and in accordance
with costeffective fiscal strategies as
authorized by the
legislature which one which once again
affirms
our
uh Reliance on inicien Energy Efficiency
programs that are cost
effective the other major changes that
the amendment makes are in section two
of the bill which starts in the
amendment on line 12 of page two in the
original bill that
was line 18 of page two
and this section just adds some
clarifying language so for example it
adds the phrase inate in front of
electricity generator to specify that
we're talking about generators that are
located here in New Hampshire not
somewhere else in the iso New England
Regional
grid and the other changes that are made
include the addition of the words or
decommissioning after retirement and the
addition of the word involuntary in
front of
retirement and then a third big change
to this section is the addition of a new
paragraph C which gives the department
of energy and the Department of Justice
the authority to seek funding from the
legislative fiscal
Committee in order to conduct any
actions that are described in the two
above and those are the big changes that
are made
to House Bill
and I made those changes in direct
response to the public hearing that we
had on this bill I listened to
everybody's comments on this bill and
made changes that I
thought would best satisfy the
objections that were made including
those by the department of
energy I think I've accommodated all
those changes in this
amendment now I still think it's
important to give the state of New
tools to
protect the health and saf safety of our
citizens by protecting our energy
Supply and there are outside
forces that could negatively affect our
instate energy Supply and we need a tool
to be able
to protect ourselves and address those
issues in court if necessary so that's
the main purpose for filing this
bill for example the state of
Massachusetts
has recently
adopted official policies
[Music]
to whenever possible prevent the
adoption of the use of natural gas
state if they continue to harm the
Marketplace the the utilities and the
vendors of natural gas may find
themselves in a position of being no no
longer financially
viable and if they go under what happens
to the pipelines that bring natural gas
to New
Hampshire that's a question that I think
we all should
contemplate and it's a question that I
think the answer
to might give us cause to think that
this bill might be useful at some point
in the
future
so having said that I'd like to hear the
reaction of the rest of the committee
and we'll have further discussions about
this uh this morning and this afternoon
representative
Kennedy thank you Mr
chairman uh what I recalled from the
public hearing was there's there was
some intimation that this bill would
somehow favor fossil
fuels um so so I I asked Mr
Roberge if the department of energy
promoted wind and solar answer
yes the next question was can you tell
me what the cumulative cost of promoting
wind and solar has been and he said he
could get that information for
me and he sent a letter an email to
myself and the rest of the
committee and the the total cost is 5
50.5
2008 a couple days later I I just
happened to be reading uh representative
uh ammon's report on nuclear
power and there was a table in the
report from the US Energy Information
Administration and it had uh a listing
of New Hampshire's energy generation mix
in
2022 along with ISO New
England so I won't read everything but
but a couple things in this table U I
think are
notable one nuclear generated 10,900
gwatt hours of electricity which was
58% of New Hampshire's
total natural gas 4,500 gaw which was
24% of new captures
total wind generated 482 gwatt hours
which is 3% of New Hampshire's
total solar generated 4 gwatt hours
0.02% uh that was rounded to zero in the
table for ISO New England uh wind
generated 4,000 gwatt hours 4% and solar
3,300 gaw which is
3% and and the only reason I bring this
up is you know maybe everyone's already
aware of this or maybe not but you know
I want to keep things real you know
where are we really with this how much
money have we spent trying to get more
wind and solar onto the grid and what's
result further discussion representative
Harrington yeah I have a a question on
the um section two loss of instate
electrical generation when it uh refers
to
um generator receives notice of an
external regulatory action that may
result in involuntary retirement or
decommissioning um what exactly are we
going to define inv voluntary ASM let me
give you an example
um uh the EPA passes a new regulation
Congress passes a new law that says you
will limit your uh emissions to a
certain amount and a gas plant in New
Hampshire looks and says if we have to
put that type of equipment on to do that
we are not going to be economically
competitive so we're not being forced to
retire we could go out and buy that
equipment and put it on there but in our
opinion it wouldn't be worth the
investment so we're going to voluntarily
retire how does that fit in with this
involuntary retirement because most to
these things it's not the federal
government which I assume who you're
referring to in most cases saying You
must shut down that plant but saying
that if you want to keep operating
here's the conditions you have to uh
live up
to it's a good question so that's the
reason I put
involuntary into the language of the
amendment obviously if it's a voluntary
retirement then they would never notify
the department of energy and the
Department would never open an
investigatory
docket only if the retirement is
involuntary will follow up or the
decommissioning is involuntary would the
uh
generator inform the commission of the
Department of energy and request some
action I guess my my question comes down
to if the a new regulation Federal
Regulation came out and a generator made
a decision saying to SP that kind of
money to be in compliance with the new
regulation would not be cost effective
so we're not being forced to close but
we choose to close because of economic
reasons would that be considered
involuntary retirement or
not if they didn't have any plans to
close before this regulation
became uh or came down from on high
somewhere and if they determine that
this regulation could potentially be
unconstitutional
then they could turn to the Department
of energy and potentially even further
redress I just think it's not clear the
term involuntary retirement maybe needs
to be defined more specifically okay
thank you for that comment
representative
Kaplan thank you Mr chair I uh I have
some questions about some of the
language around the state's Sovereign
authority over generation facilities
uh correct me if I'm wrong but most of
these generation facilities are private
companies and so what would what would
constitute the state's Sovereign
authority to make any decision over
their operation or or their U or their
not so the state's sovereignty is
guaranteed by the 10th Amendment of the
United States
Constitution and the state can exercise
that Authority when it feels it needs to
do that's what the body of this
legislation sets up as a framework for
the state to do that if it determines
necessary did you need a followup yeah
followup so are you suggesting that the
the state could step in and overrule uh
so to speak uh EPA regulations for
example
no I'm suggesting that the state for
just for Just Cause could
challenge an EPA regulation if it if it
thought that said regulation was
unconstitutional so the kind of thing
that this legislation is trying to head
off is when Regulatory
Agencies create regulations that are not
authorized by
Congress and that has has happened
repeatedly over the last 25 years the
EPA has been challenged in court
numerous times
and this legislation gives New Hampshire
a way to participate in that if it so
desires based on protecting an instate
generation resource followup yeah one
more followup that seems to be
predicated uh uh Mr Mr chairman on on a
Supreme Court decision that hasn't
really come down yet if you're talking
about Chevron deference to Regulatory
Agencies um as far as as I'm I'm aware
those Regulatory Agencies have the right
to make those rules so no it's not
predicated upon it I did discuss it in
the public hearing when I introduced the
bill the EPA has been taken to court
multiple
times and there have been various
decisions made about the constit
constitutionality of some of the
regulations that they've
uh offered some have been overruled some
have been have been
upheld the question is does New
Hampshire have any real legal way to
object if a rule potentially can hurt an
instate generation
facility representative Ms thank you Mr
chairman um like representative
Harrington I had a question on um page
two the section two on page two but mine
mine was a little little little
different um I guess I my my question is
does does external Rel regulatory action
does that apply to action regulatory
actions by state agencies as well and
and I can think of two examples that
could result in the involuntary
retirement or decommissioning of a
generators facility one is the de the
Department of Environmental Services
decid
Ides that um it's in the best interest
to eliminate a dam on a river that and
that Dam happens to also be a Electric
electrical generating
facility um I if that happens does that
uh generator have the ability to uh
petition the commissioner and the
Attorney General to take action and then
another example that um um you know we
spent quite a bit of time talking about
last year is if for example the Pu
issues an order um um kind of U abating
an agreement that a power generator such
as the Burgess biomass plant has entered
into um making it unattractive for that
business to continue operating and then
the legislature on top of that you know
introduces some um some um significant
uh Financial um hurdles that they have
to
cross if this is passed does that give
does this give the Burgess biomass plant
the opportunity to petition the
commissioner and the attorney general or
does this apply strictly to Federal
regulatory um
action well because it it does discuss
in its
Preamble the 10th Amendment
rights of the state to protect its
Sovereign Sovereign Authority it is
aimed more at National rather than
instate activity regulatory activity
instate regulatory
activity is under the control of the
legislature as we set policy for that so
that this particular legislation
probably would not be invoked in that
situation but it could be
hello
testing testing hello oh mine's is
mine's
on hello hello hello hello hello hello
oh I guess it's back on okay I don't
know what happened there all right well
that now that we've got everyone's
attention
um so the point I want to make is I want
to sort of pull back the Gaze again uh
on this one which this is basically a
rewrite of New Hampshire's energy policy
which is uh 378 37 and it's very much a
departure
from existing um language and
so this is more protectionist and from
sort of the state's perspective that we
have to guard generating Assets in order
to make sure we don't run out of stuff
that we need but we are part of a
regional grid system and we had
testimony which was pretty extensive and
also succinct from the New Hampshire New
Hampshire um power generators
Association and they are responsible for
the wholesale markets and they talked
about how this could have the unintended
consequence of actually take taking us
in the opposite direction and stifling
Innovation for
um for changes that happen because the
market puts those pressures out there
and so um when I look at uh the language
that says that we have a duty to defend
the production and supply of affordable
reliable and secure energy and then it
says you know from these particular
people but it says that we have that
Duty and I the first thing I thought
when I read the original amendment I
wrote do we because um I understand the
idea that if we have uh if we have seab
Brook and it's producing 58% of the
generation in the State Electric
generation and most of that energy is
being bought by other folks on the
regional grid so we're not necessarily
benefiting from all of that
energy but that asset located in our
state is an asset that we would seek to
protect but we would have to do that
through the
existing um bodies of uh you know
regulatory bodies and and infrastructure
that currently exists we can't vote
ourselves into more power than than we
have and our doj already has the
authority to bring a suit anytime
something comes against the state that
we would think would be against State
interests we don't need to change the
state's position on energy policy uh in
order to have that Authority so we're
not granting ourselves any additional
Authority we're just saying that we want
to interpret the 10th Amendment of the
US Constitution as providing us with
authority to provide these protections
and the last thing I'll say on this is
those protections are in the eye of the
beholder because in many cases the
changes in policy that are coming down
are because many of the powers that be
in the federal government are concerned
about much
larger um impacts to human health and
environmental um
degradation and that is the whole reason
for the efforts that people have been
making for the last 30 or 40 years so
it's it's in the eye of the beholder and
my problem with this bill and this
language is
that it is not something that we all
agree to as far as how energy policy
should be described in our state
statutes it's a very much a departure
and and as well um NEPA had asked us
really not to do this basically for the
unintended consequences that they could
see happening um to um representative
kaplan's point to private plants which
are going
through going through their own um
changes based on the need for cleaner
power so what what they said in their
testimony was this could have the
unintended consequence of alleviating
people from making those changes at a
time when it would be really helpful if
they would be doing that so um I think
it puts it puts a finger on the scale of
how we approach energy policy that is as
I said very much a departure from where
the state has been for the last 30 years
and so I can't vote for it because I
don't think it I don't think it serves
us and I also don't think it um I don't
think it comes from a place where it
understands both how the system works
and um and how the regulatory piece
works right it it it seems to be devoid
of understanding that we're part of a
regional grid so we just really don't
have this doesn't give us any more
Authority is I guess what I'm trying to
say the bill doesn't really help us do
anything um so I I can't see muddying
the waters which we've now used to
describe every single bill that we've
reviewed this morning but I just don't
see muddying the Waters of State energy
energ policy uh with something like this
that says we're going to have to get out
and legally defend uh the life of of
power plants which are morphing and
transitioning and changing based on the
free market I I just I don't think
doing seems like oh here we go okay well
mine's working thank you Mr chairman for
recognizing me and um yeah my comments
will be I guess unsurprisingly along the
lines
of my ranking members comments I too
went and you know of course looked at
the existing uh statute and I found you
know the the New Hampshire energy policy
existing law
section
um the site right here 3787 378 37 to be
be you know a rather elegant uh
73w total of 73 words uh general
statement that mentions things we all
support agree on as as policy goals
lowest reasonable cost reliability
diversity of energy
resources uh cost effective Energy
Efficiency and other demand side
resources are in there uh along with of
course uh safety and health so you know
Mr chairman I I don't um have no doubt
about your your sincerity obviously and
concern you know for for New Hampshire's
energy security and the welfare of the
citizens of New Hampshire I just um have
uh real concern as as representative
McGee expressed with this sort
of um you
know alternative statement
of what that can consists of how to
achieve energy security for for the
State of New Hampshire and uh
particularly to um you know and I
appreciate your work on the amendment um
you're you're hearing uh or you're
listening at the public hearing and
responding to the concerns like
elimination of the word dispatchable and
and some of the other changes you made I
do appreciate that but my my remaining
concerns really are still with the
continued inclusion of uh inclusion of
one concept and the exclusion of another
concept which you know the word
diversity of energy resources you have
you are you would be taking out of New
Hampshire's energy
policy um and you specifically uh
include in particular you know paragraph
1A of your um Amendment continues to
state that the the state of New
Hampshire shall work to ensure the
states energy
Independence um I just think you know
law New Hampshire law has no business
including a statement like that because
May well the notion of energy
totally it is totally
facius New
Hampshire and really every state in New
England is the farthest thing from
energy
independent that a state could
be um while we may have a
um um nuclear power plant located within
our boundaries uh it's a plant that
serves the region not simply New
Hampshire and New Hampshire has no
Authority or means to uh one day you
know somehow order that plant to only
serve the state of New Hampshire so you
know seab Brook is a big generating
asset and it may be within our borders
but it serves the region in of which we
are a part
um you
know and and a vast majority of the
energy we uh use besides uh coming from
seab Brook is from fossil fuels and of
course New Hampshire or and New England
has none of those all of those are
imported to this region as you mentioned
via pipelines and we remain um um highly
dependent on or I should say you know
extremely vulnerable to disruptions in
in those uh weather events acts of War
you know the price of gas natural gas
spikes and the state experiences what we
what we did uh the a couple of years
ago in in uh price spikes for our
electricity so you know if if we're
going to pass a new law or make a new
statement about um energy security for
the State of New Hampshire you know it's
I don't think it's going to be found uh
either in that you know felicious notion
of energy Independence or in sort of
exer uh asserting a new sort of state
power over private Market uh generation
assets that we somehow might be able to
command to continue uh operating or
something you know rather the state's
energy policy should uh embrace
uh not in not Independence but
interdependence the interdependence that
we have with
our um New England neighbors as well as
our our neighbor uh North in Canada as
well as embracing going back to the
other word that I mentioned the
diversity uh of energy resources that
power our economy today and liberate us
from overdependence on any one asset or
thoughts hello oh mine's
working hello oh now it's working okay
all right so we have three minutes left
word
working
everybody I have a working mic cross
your fingers that it stays that way for
a
while we're here for an executive
session on three bills this afternoon
we're going to be looking at House Bill
1036 relative to assessment of cost
effectiveness of the system benefits
charge House Bill 1600 relative to
participation in net energy
metering and House Bill 1623 relative to
the state energy policy we had an
extensive full committee work session on
all three bills this morning we think we
have a pretty good idea about how things
are going to go this
afternoon and one little wrinkle that
happened that I wasn't made aware of
until about two minutes ago is that
representative Lucius parshall who
wasn't here this morning is also not
going to be here this afternoon
apparently Lucius is sick we wish him a
speedy recovery and hope he gets well
very very soon so we can see him uh
sooner rather than
later
and the house rule is that you can't
replace a member unless you
notify the relevant staff 24 hours in
advance but I have asked representative
McGee to go and see if she can because
these are extraordinary
circumstances M representative partial
didn't know he was going to be sick
until he woke up this morning so I've
asked if we can get a replacement on
short notice um speaker office she's
calling the staff and speaker I guess I
don't know who she's calling but she's
she's working on
it you probably should alert the speaker
too not I'm sure the speaker will get
involved yes I'm sure the speaker will
get
involved I believe Mr chairman that's a
house rule right representative
Harrington I believe that's a house rule
then we can't wave house rules can we
I'm I can't but maybe the speaker can
that's why I asked her to double
check so we will proceed one way or the
other with this ex with executive
session I'd prefer that we had uh both
Co fuses at full strength but we'll see
what happens representative
clog thank you chair I'd just like to
thank the chair for reaching out to the
minority leadership I almost did not
make it in today um last night probably
for a similar reason it sounds um I
cleared up nothing contagious just one
of those things I was going to call you
at 2: in the morning thank you much as I
like you Tom please don't call me at two
whatever the reason all right so there's
one other matter I want to discuss with
you all before we start our first
executive session and that is at the
beginning of the of the day today I
mentioned that I had visited the clerk
to talk about the gerain of an amendment
to house bill for
1644 which we passed 20 to nothing last
Tuesday and the clerk informed me during
the lunch break that he and the speaker
had determined that that amendment is
not
Germain therefore the bill can't go
forward as written or as
submitted so what I'm going to do is I'm
going to make a motion on the house
floor well first uh representative McGee
is going to pull the bill off consent
because that's where it currently
resides and then I'm going to make a
motion on the house floor to refer the
bill for interim
study and I would encourage you all to
motion
1644 it's on the consent
calendar it was a 20 to nothing vote
but we will refer it now for interim
study and before I start this NE next
executive session I'm going to ask
representative McGee if she had any
well okay so since uh representative
McGee was not able to get any relief
from the speaker's
office I just had a conference with
representative n and she has some other
business to transact so she is going to
leave so that we'll have an equal equal
representation okay so representative
nder you're
excused and we thank you for making that
offer so with that I'm going to open an
executive session on House Bill 1600 FN
and I'm going to recognize
representative Corman for a
motion thank you Mr
chairman uh for House Bill 1600 FN I
move ought to pass with Amendment with
Amendment
224-7629 H which I distributed to
everybody
beforehand okay so representative Corman
moves the adoption of amendment
0764 and I second that motion so it has
been moved and seconded that we adopt
this amendment and
I'll the chair will recognize
representative Corman to
discuss thank you uh as we talked about
during the work session this amendment
uh has basically the same idea in the
first part as the original Bill where a
municipal host that is using its power
to offset the load of a municipal or
County aggregation uh then it is not
going to be considered part of default
service not in the load requirements of
of iso New England and therefore um what
we should be seeing would be uh less
requirement in the transmission lines
and therefore saving money for everybody
with lower transmission requirements and
then part two of the amendment is really
just housekeeping that says that um the
part of RSA
53e 4 that refers to customer data it's
that okay thank you very much I forgot
to mention earlier that we have a
visitor a substitute today that's
Charlie Melvin um sitting in for James
summer so thank you Charlie for being
here all right further discussion on
this
legislation seeing none I'll point out
that we are going to vote both for the
amendment and then for the motion of
ought to pass so I'll ask the clerk to
call the role on the motion of ought to
4 Vice chair Thomas
yes is here representative Harrington
yes representative Lei yes
representative uh Bry yes representative
Bernardi yes representative PL yes
representative Melvin yes representative
Kennedy yes representative McGee yes
representative MC Williams yes
representative crean yes representative
Kaplan yes representative muns yes
representative Noel yes representative
Thomas yes representative Corman yes
representative rolds yes chairman Vos
yes
180 by a vote of 18 to zero the
committee adopt the committee amendment
20247 64h is
adopted I now recognize representative
Corman for a motion thank you Mr
chairman I move ought to pass for 16
hb600 FN ought to pass as amended with
Amendment
0764 and I second that motion so it's
been moved and seconded that we adopt
hb600 FN as amended by 2024
seeing none when he's ready I'll ask the
clerk to call the role on the motion of
hb600 Vice chair Thomas
yes representative Harrington yes
representative licki yes representative
Bry yes representative Bernardi yes
representative PL yes representative
Melvin yes representative Kennedy yes
representative McGee yes representative
McWilliams yes representative crean yes
representative Kaplan yes representative
muns yes representative Noel yes
representative Thomas yes representative
Corman yes representative rolds yes
180 okay by a vote of 18 to Z the
committee adopts the motion of about to
pass as amended for House Bill 1600 as
24764 without objection we'll put this
calendar hearing no objections on
consent it will go I thank you
and representative Corman will write the
committee report and I need that before
you leave uh the building this afternoon
thank you I need to correct the tense
it's already written
okay all right so with that we'll close
1600 and now we'll open an exact session
paperwork here recognizes representative
Harrington for a motion I move adoption
of amendment
1036 yeah I think what you meant was
63h that is correct
H okay great I second that
motion and I recognize representative
Harrington to discuss the
amendment well I recognize we discussed
this for a long time this morning I
don't think anyone's going to change
their mind so there's really not much
point in discussing it
discussion representative McGee yeah Mr
chair I would just say that I think
among my caucus we thought that the
amendment was preferable to the original
bill so we're still we're voting for the
amendment whether we like it or not and
then the bill as amended right so we
have two two votes correct correct we
will vote on the amendment first
discussion okay seeing none I'll ask the
clerk to call the role on the question
of the adoption of the amendment 0
1036 Vice chair Thomas yes
representative Harrington yes
representative lii yes representative
Bry yes representative Bernardi yes
representative yes representative Melvin
yes representative Kennedy yes
representative McGee yes representative
McWilliams yes representative crean yes
no representative
Ms yes representative Noel yes
representative Thomas yes representative
Corman yes represent rolds yes chairman
Vose yes 171 by a vote of
171 the amendment
that brings us
to the question of ought to pass as
amended the chair recognizes
representative Harrington I move to um
pass Amendment uh let me get this right
now 2024
0763 onto a Amendment I'm sorry onto HB
1036 so as amended ought to pass so you
move ought to pass as amended on House
Bill
1036 correct
okay I second that
motion and I will re reiterate some of
what I said this morning
namely that this bill does
not obligate the Public Utilities
Commission to make any changes to the
existing cost Effectiveness formulas
that are used to
determine if energ Energy Efficiency
programs are cost effective it does not
mandate any changes but what it does do
is it gives the commission
flexibility that if something better
comes down the pike in the next two or
three years that they can look at it and
consider whether there isn't a better
way to evaluate Energy Efficiency cost
Effectiveness that's all this
legislation does I think it's the kind
of public policy that we ought to be
providing as guidance to our Regulatory
Agencies and I think we should
adopt House Bill 1036 as
amended further
discussion representative
Kaplan thank you Mr chair I I agree that
the amended version is is a better
version uh but I still can't vote for
this bill as amended uh because I think
U that the flexibility already exist
statute and this would be opening up a
can of worms that's already been
adjudicated and U is not in the best
interest of my constitu so I can't be I
discussion well seeing none I guess I'll
ask the clerk we did talk about it
extensively this morning so I'll ask the
clerk to call the role on the question
of ought to pass as amended on House
Bill
Vice chair Thomas
yes representative Harrington yes
representative Wicky yes representative
brne yes representative Bernardi yes
representative PL yes representative
Melvin yes representative Kennedy yes
representative McGee no representative
MC Williams no Representative crean no
representative Kaplan no representative
Ms no representative Noel no
representative Thomas no representative
Corman no Representative rolds no
chairman Vose
yes nine to
nine by a vote of nine to nine the
motion of ought to pass as amended
fails so the bill will go to the house
recommendation who will write the
um representative Harrington I should
say will write the um report for ought
to pass who will write the motion for or
the report for itl I will Mr chair
representative McGee will write the
report
for
itl okay I would like that before you
leave today if
possible if you can't uh do it today
then let me know
why ditto representative
Harrington okay I can let you know why
right now I for some reason my email
won't work here so I can't send it to
you I'll send it to you when I get home
okay all right so with that we'll close
1036 and I'll open an EXA session on
House Bill 1623 relative to State energy
policy
and I am passing out a new
amendment that was
crafted during the lunch
0782 and this amendment was while it's
working its way around to you I will
explain what it
does if you go to page
Amendment
it
the previous Amendment on that line read
that may result in the involuntary
retirement or decommissioning of the
generator's
facility the amendment changes that to
read that makes continued operation
economically infeasible or may result in
the invent involuntary retirement or
decommissioning of the generator's
facility so it basically adds the phrase
makes
continued operation economically
infeasible or it adds that text it's
line 14
not4 oh I'm sorry line 14 if I said four
I misspoke my apologies yeah that's line
14 that's where this change gets made
and that is the only change to um that
this amendment
makes and um we discussed it extensively
this
morning so I'd like to hear any further
Amendment or further discussion on this
it we didn't make any motions okay I'm
sorry I move the adoption of amendment
Thomas
second moved and seconded that we adopt
the amendment now we can have a
discussion representative McGee thank
you Mr chairman I would just like to
reiterate my
my perspective that the the amendment as
well as the original Amendment
are unworkable because they attempt to
redefine how the electric system works
um and how it is regulated by um stating
that that the state has an interest in
private businesses and I think that goes
against our general position that we are
for free markets and we understand that
these generating facilities are not
under our
jurisdiction and we understand what the
system is that does have jurisdiction
and how we would have to interact with
them if we were trying to save a
particular generating facility so I just
I just still don't think this this is
workable language thanks Vice chair
Thomas thank you Mr chair um I think
this amendment clarifies an issue uh
that some Representatives had earlier
and adds to the existing bill so I think
in any event this amendment does make
the bill better and I will be supporting
it further discussion
representative Ms thank you Mr chair um
I I too have some continued concerns
with the language in the bill um the the
change in this amendment uh well it
certainly addresses um one of the issues
that I think I had raised with respect
to the um the Burgess biomass plant um
I'm still not clear what an external
regulatory action is and whether that
applies to um
state or or federal
authorities and um I um I continue to
struggle with the
numerous cases where the word sovereign
and Sovereign Authority is included in
the um in the um in the bill and um not
not sure that that's necessary and
concerned as to why it's in there so I
won't will not be able to support this
amendment thank you further
discussion
representative
bernardy thank you Mr chair I think this
bill confirms that in the end the state
is the ultimate Sovereign Authority on
the need to uh and the having the the
responsibility to ensure there is power
available within the state after all
other regulatory Avenues have been
pursued at the end of the day the state
is the ultimate sovereign
further discussion representative
reels thank you Mr chairman um I I
appreciate uh I think that the most
recent amendment is a is a a slight
Improvement to the prior Amendment but I
um you know I have to have to push back
on
um my colleague representative Bernard's
assertion that this bill could possibly
make the state of New Hampshire the
ultimate
um Authority we the state of New
Hampshire in no way has the uh
information the analytical
capability uh let alone the um legal
authority to do
what ISO New England and the North
American uh electric reliability
Corporation are in fact legally
charged with doing by the Federal Energy
Regulatory Commission which is having
the responsibility
to continuously Monitor and
manage the regional electric grid and
ensure reliability for everyone on it
all six New England states so I just
this idea that New Hampshire in the end
would uh have either the the knowledge
or the authority to to do what this bill
envisions uh uh is is just I think not
there and uh in addition I'll just
briefly restate what I something I said
earlier I don't think that language that
uh asserts that the state of New
Hampshire could ever be uh is or could
ever be energy
independent uh has any place in New
Hampshire law we are very far from
energy independent and uh security you
know the state of Texas as large as that
is uh that years ago asserted their
desire to be energy independent and to
actually be their own uh electric
grid they finally learned that even even
they could not be uh security was not
found in being energy independent in in
the huge cold snap that they experienced
a couple years ago when their their grid
went down
gas plants
failed uh transmission lines failed uh
certainly the state of New Hampshire
will never be energy independent and we
shouldn't
um state it as a policy goal that that
we're going to be instead we should
embrace uh our interdependence and the
other word diversity of energy resources
so can't support this
bill further discussion representative
Thomas thank you Mr chair um this is a
question I guess for you on the
amendment um on page two line 20 it it
says that um they the department of
energy is is mandated to recommend any
action necessary to defend the
generator however there's
no there's no inclusion of public
benefit or Community impact even though
through it the the top of the page on
page one you talk about health safety
and Welfare health safety and Welfare
you it's mentioned a few times so why is
not the health safety and Welfare
considered under this mandate I guess
question well because this paragraph
pertains to the involuntary retirement
right but but what you're saying is that
if a plant has has an involuntary
retirement or decommissioning that the
department of educa uh Department of
energy sorry is recommending must
recommend any action necessary to defend
the
generator but shouldn't those actions
also consider public benefit and
Community
impact well that recommendation would be
based on the results of the
investigatory docket to determine how
such an involuntary retirement or
decommissioning would affect the
reliability and affordability of the
resources okay I think we're ship's
passing in the night but thank you thank
you further
discussion representative
kapin yes this uh uh thank you Mr chair
this is sort of along the lines of
represented Wendy Thomas's uh concerns I
I just wonder how
um the state is going to step in on
behalf of private generators when it's
determined that external regulatory
action makes their operation
economically
unfeasible uh I I just I mean I
understand the chair's sort of
ideological position that the Regulatory
Agencies at the federal level ought to
be backed up by a legislative mandate
but I just fear that this is going to
put us at odds with federal regulations
and is based on
a you know a flawed view of of our
sovereignty and how that you know how
that means that that it's it's you know
the Federal Regulations still have
Supremacy and and we need to not be
writing something that goes contrary to
that in our in our official policy on
energy
so I can't vote for this bill even
additional
discussion Vice chair Thomas thank you
Mr chair um I just like to reiterate
that whether it's one argument whether
or not uh the state can actually U uh
has the ability to uh physically perform
some of these actions I think the point
I'd like to refer back to what
representative Bernardi said is that
this is just a reaffirmation of the
state's right under the 10th Amendment
which uh far as I can recollect back in
you know in the 1700s there was no
mention of electric grid in the
Constitution so all powers not expressly
prohibited in the Constitution fall back
on the state so I think this is just a
reaffirmation that the state has the
right not saying has the ability or
capability or even the materials to
carry forward but they at least have the
right to challenge and to um do certain
laws as to for the to protect the
welfare of of its people here which
would be the power grid so although this
bill may not have a whole lot of teeth
to it I think the point is that it's
saying the state does reserve its right
to challenge these regulations under the
10th
Amendment representative Ms thank you Mr
chair with with all due respect to to
representative Doug Thomas
um that's not all this bill does this
bill eliminates or changes dramatically
the state's energy policy and if the
intent was to um introduce legislation
to reassert the state's 10th Amendment
rights doing that and and eliminating
the state's energy policy would not be
the appropriate way to do
discussion seeing
none
representative McGee it did just come to
me so uh on that point of this affecting
the state the stated State energy policy
um we have multiple vehicles that are
rewriting the state energy policy this
time around on both sides of the wall so
um I another reason that I wouldn't vote
for this particular legislation is that
this is the one that is counter to the
other um the other two vehicles that
have been passed which are more in
keeping with the existing policy and I
think if we are going to undertake uh
and about face on what we are listing as
New Hampshire's priorities in terms of
energy policy this should be a more full
some process than what we've had here
today um because this doesn't reflect
what it was mentioned earlier uh in the
work session uh I believe 72 words or
something I think Ned wrote red it it's
it's succinct it's elegant um and it was
pulled together over time to really
Encompass all of the things that we're
trying to accomplish with our energy
policy and I think that the language in
this bill would replace that language
and it would um it would leave us
wanting on a number of areas that were
mentioned in that original policy which
are preserved in both the house bill and
the Senate bill that um seek to modify
that energy policy with with the um the
IRP right the um the integrated resource
planning uh language that we're trying
to reinstate that we took out of the
281 so the state's consumer Advocate
wrote in a recent
article right now and I quote right now
RS 378 colon7 37 is a malage of mixed
messages there are references to keeping
utilities financially healthy to
protecting the safety and health of our
citizens to maximizing maximizing the
use of
costeffective Energy
Efficiency and
Etc
so if there is a malange of
contradictory messages there then maybe
we should replace it thank you Mr chair
and I'd just like to say that I read the
article and he he also goes on to say
discussion seeing none I'll ask the
clerk to call the role on the question
40782 Vice shair Thomas yes
representative Harrington yes
representative lii yes representative
Bry yes representative Bernardi yes
representative PL yes representative
Melvin yes representative Kennedy yes
representative McGee no representative
MC Williams no Representative crean no
representative Kaplan no Representative
muns no Representative noell no
representative Thomas no representative
Corman no Representative rolds no
chairman Vose
yes 9 to
n nine to nine so by a vote of nine to
fails and so does the bill so it will go
to the house floor without
recommendation I will write the report
for the motion of ought to pass as
amended
and representative McGee who will write
the report for uh representative Kaplan
representative Kaplan will write the
report
for
itl and representative Kaplan get that
to me as quickly as you can preferably
before you leave here
today okay with that we are done I'm
going to close the executive session on
House Bill
1623 is is there any other business that
needs to come before the committee
day I did not I did not so
representative McGee wants to pull HB
1644 off the consent calendar but you
need 10 people to support that motion
can we get 10 people here who will
so I will send a note to the clerk and
I'll CC everyone on stn and then whoever
wants to just send their name into him
you'll be on the list and he'll take
he'll take the first 10 so thank you
okay anything
else representative MC Williams do we
have any future meetings scheduled
anything upcoming for work for the
committee no there are no future
meetings scheduled and we will not plan
to meet again until March 15th when we
England representative Bernardi so we we
have nothing scheduled but we have uh
requests for doe and
Dees to uh provide us a
um discussion about issues that you guys
are sending me uh and I ask that they
select days in March and get back when
they can do that so it's possible that
the first Tuesday in March could be one
of those days I don't know right now the
only firm date we have a meeting is the
March okay everybody clear on that we
Thursday